hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new galaxy z full 3 and today i'm
so excited to compare against my iphone
12 pro max because i will be switching
over and experiencing a foldable phone
for the first time ever i have skipped
out on the previous iterations because i
just were not good enough to use as a
daily phone but today you guys will see
my first impression and holy moly that
is one big screen it's cool how the box
is so wide let's peel this thing back
nice i love the all black look
wow this thing is thinner than i
expected so that is good since we're
gonna have to fold it looking on this
side man you can clearly see this is not
glass or at least the coating on top
that fold is very noticeable but let's
go ahead and try to fold this for the
first time
oh that feels crazy and now wow you
didn't feel the weight that much before
but now this thing feels substantial but
it feels premium and really high quality
like a solid kind of brick
in your hand now today we're not only
going to compare the physical design and
comfort but also the speakers the
displays the brightness we're gonna take
a look at the cameras and much more now
my biggest concern when i was ordering
this phone is just how substantial it's
gonna be just how big it is but looking
at it next to my iphone you see it is
much more narrow it's slightly shorter
and the main difference is thickness on
the hinge side it's about twice as thick
and close to it on the opposite side and
then when you flip it open it's actually
thinner than the iphone which is already
a super thin phone and holding in my
hand this way this is incredibly
comfortable just because of how narrow
it is so i'm curious how the comfort is
going to be when i'm using just the
front screen and of course once we open
it up maybe you can one-handed use it
but you're only going to access a tiny
portion of the screen it's definitely a
phablet now i want to use it with the
s-pen so i did get this little kit along
with it and i have to say it really is a
shame that samsung did not build in a
slot for an s pen even if it was a
tinier one because adding this on i mean
look at that guys you have a lot more
bulk it's thicker and you have this
whole section i think this should just
slide off
yeah but you got to keep this with you
separately which is a bummer yeah i
can't see myself using this case in this
setup for long it is just way too bulky
and this flap is so annoying so with
that i actually got a couple other
things i got the new galaxy but i got
the watch so i will be switching over
for at least a week and doing a follow
up video how a foldable phone is to use
in the real world especially switching
over from an iphone so if you guys want
to see that or a camera comparison
between this phone and the iphone which
both don't have those uh telephoto
telescopic cameras and the s21 ultra the
blind comparison go ahead and click that
subscribe button down below and with
that you guys can help us hit our goal
of 1 million subscribers all right and
our screen is on i've been logging in
it's just very interesting to use such a
narrow display it's tall but when you
have to like type it is weird compared
to this nice large display on the iphone
so in order to add our fingerprint let's
go ahead and open this thing up bam and
look at that screen now first time i'm
seeing it with it turned on that is a
massive difference i cannot wait to try
out some call of duty mobile on this
phone you guys let me know do you guys
want to see a gaming video pitting this
one testing to see the battery life and
if it has any dimming overheating
compared to the iphone you guys can
comment down below but for now let's go
ahead and add the fingerprint and our
scanner is right there on the side and
of course when it's closed using the
front screen that's your power button so
it's all in one now before we compare
the displays i'm really curious about
contrast and brightness and hdr video if
i'm gonna have a worse experience
compared to my iphone let's jump right
in and test out the speakers
[Music]
all right guys that was interesting you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below
but i was pleasantly surprised with the
galaxy fold now i wasn't expecting that
much because the speakers are only on
one side and when you're holding it you
can actually block the speakers with
your hands if you want to hold it the
opposite way so they're floating at the
top
then what ends up happening is you are
touching your camera right over here
getting fingerprints all over but with
that said and i didn't do this in the
test if you're holding it this way and
you make sure your hands are opened up
you end up getting that little cupping
effect where it bounces all the sound to
your ears and it sounds extremely
balanced on both sides because we do not
have an earpiece speaker we just have
one on top one on bottom so they're
identical speakers so it's not louder on
one side or more rich on one side so
overall i'm very impressed with these
speakers actually there is an earpiece
speaker just on the other side it's a
little cut out but it could be using
that same speaker that faces up so
overall that is a great design now let's
take a look at this gorgeous display the
first thing that i have to mention is
that crease in the display now i know
people said it's better but it is
definitely noticeable even on a white
screen
looking at it with it bright i always
notice it on a black screen it is very
noticeable and then just swiping it just
feels weird it is not a great experience
with that i noticed that little camera
cut out all the time as well i kind of
wish that they just didn't put one in
there at all the fingerprint scanner on
the side is plenty for authentication i
guess if you want to do video
conferencing that's a reason
but it just it doesn't look great but at
least it's better than that little weird
notch thing they did with the first gen
and the next thing is reflectivity man
this display is a lot more reflective
than the iphone so it looks like maybe
the coding that they have to do to keep
it safe is just pretty much like a
mirror especially on black content and
in order to combat that reflection we
need brightness this was also a weak
spot of the previous folds let's go
ahead and max it completely out we're
going to set it to manual medium go
ahead and expose for the phones and
based on that camera you guys can see
that at least in manual mode the iphone
is a lot brighter now go ahead and take
these outside and here's a clip of how
they look in auto brightness mode and as
you can see they are basically identical
when you leave it in that mode the
samsung just can't get as bright if
you're doing it yourself to save battery
power and as far as viewing angles the
iphone is definitely better it doesn't
shift that much with color or brightness
where as a samsung it's a lot more blue
from the side and you do see it dim so
overall as far as contrast and the
creases the iphone definitely takes the
win of course one of the biggest
differences in the display apart from it
folding is the fact that we have 120
hertz display support for the samsung
not only on the internal screen but also
on the external screen as well and this
makes everything much smoother so take a
look at the slow motion footage
let's do the last test what i'm most
excited for and that is watching hdr
video i went ahead and i adjusted that
top camera so the highlights aren't
blown out and take a look at that
that hdr video on the samsung galaxy
fold 3 looks better the highlights are
popping more the contrast is shockingly
looking better as well
that looks crisp and because of the
larger display it just looks great look
at that white that just popping it might
even still be blowing out that camera
vadim what do you think what do you see
here yeah yeah the fold is definitely
better i'm surprised huh even with a
foldable screen i guess it's their
latest tech and then of course we have
to deal with notch on the iphone this is
a different aspect ratio but let's
stretch it out and see what we get
gosh look at that look at that notch
getting in the way there we're here
yeah i still notice that little grid but
it is way better than having a notch
yeah much deeper blocks there yeah
you're right much deeper blacks
the highlights are popping more that is
gorgeous hdr honestly guys i am very
surprised
because i thought the iphone screen
would be better and now let's talk about
performance i have geekbench 5 opened up
right here and as we see we have the a14
6 gigs of ram compared to the latest
snapdragon 888 which has
eight cores and actually has 12 gigs of
ram but of course that doesn't tell the
whole story so let's go ahead and run
this test all right and that's actually
not that bad multi-core we're looking at
3349 compared to 4 000 and this phone
actually used to score about 4 200 but
it's almost a year old and i'm having
some thermal issues with this so it's
slower a little bit single core though
we're almost 1600 compared to 1133
that's a 40
difference in single core and a 20
difference in multi-core but of course
these are just numbers day-to-day we
will see if i actually notice a
difference in my follow-up one week real
world review now we're also going to
test out the graphics but first before
that i want to do a 5g speed test
because this phone right here has a
newer modem so let's go ahead and pop in
my sim alright guys look at this on the
iphone we have two out of four bars and
on the samsung we have four out of five
wow the iphone just jumped back down to
one out of four so it looks like we have
worst reception but that doesn't tell
the whole story so i'm connected to the
same exact server here and we're pulling
you know from the same tower just like
thousands of cars do at the same time
whoa okay yeah there we go
we're seeing a pretty dang good
difference right now we have 50 megabit
per second compared to 160 on the
download 180
190 it just keeps going and for upload
we're looking at about 18 compared to
pretty much the same so they're about
the same there now that is a significant
difference of course this is just in one
spot in a concrete building i will be
using this thing all around town i'm
excited to see how well it's gonna work
now let's go ahead and jump into the
graphics test this is 3dmark's newly
updated test we're going to use wildlife
extreme
in the unlimited mode so let's go ahead
and get started all right and this is
actually a significant difference we
have 2062 on the iphone compared to 1
255 score for the samsung that is a
difference of 64
and that is massive now of course that
does not take into account um
overheating or thermal throttling after
gaming for a while so if you guys want
to see that gaming test go ahead and let
us know and now let's talk about the
cameras we have three on the back of
each phone and then on the front we have
one more for selfie shots and with that
as you guys know we have that special
under display camera when you open up
the galaxy fold and this is the one that
i'm most curious about now i know the
ones on the back are gonna be decent and
we're gonna have that blind camera
comparison against the iphone and
against the samsung that would be an
awesome video but i just want to see how
bad is this front-facing camera
all right oh interesting so as soon as
you're actually using it if you guys see
at the front there that little grid goes
away we'll turn off that annoying
smoothness thing that they always kick
in from the factory and let's take a
look at this thing okay
so i can go wider a little bit wider
there but it's interesting to see all
the noise that i see present in my face
i'm not used to that maybe five years
ago on iphones and android phones now
let's go ahead and take a picture
and this thing is going to do some
processing
bam you guys see that was really blurry
oh gosh that still looks terrible
that looks really really bad all right
so of course you guys don't have to use
that but let's just do a quick little
comparison shot with the iphone's front
camera and you guys let me know how big
of a difference can you notice once this
image is posted online and compressed is
it that big of a deal of course if you
don't want to use that we also have this
one in the front that is way better
but we will see in our ultimate blind
camera comparison so what is the verdict
well
this has got to be the hardest verdict
really these phones are very different
but they are both the leading edge of
technology obviously apple is playing it
safe samsung is making an incredible
piece of technology that they're
iterating upon and this thing has so
much more to offer there are downsides
such as the bend and the display the
thickness the fact that the s pen is not
built in but you do actually have an s
pen and you can actually multitask
with this phone you can have multiple
windows open like this you can have
three open
this is just an incredible device and i
will really have to test it out longer
to see if it is worth the eighteen
hundred dollars compared to the eleven
hundred dollars here of course with the
eighteen hundred dollars you do get some
extras you get more ssd storage space or
internal storage space there's no sd
card built in but 512 is good enough for
most people you get all these different
cameras i'm just excited to use this
every single day and see if it is worth
it if now is the time to upgrade to a
foldable phone from an iphone if you
want to be on the bleeding edge you guys
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below click that circle
above to subscribe and help us reach our
goal of a million subscribers check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been max and i will see
you in the next video
[Music]